what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to continue
reach our episode dose today we are not
dos Cavazos though
listen guys uh we're gonna leave you a
like by you leaving and uh hey thanks to
everyone who joining our patreon full
interaction watch as long as we single
with your own copy available for super
sexy rejects over there and we cover a
bunch of stuff exclusively as well
subscribe and click that notification
Bell you know the drill
is there anything else oh yeah
say hi to your mom
she makes me breakfast this morning
talking smack
it's gonna be fun reaction
come all-nighters this week I'm sorry
guys let's do it
[Music]
where do you think you're going richer
Richard get back here follow him make
sure he doesn't ruin our case why me
outside the morgue you actually listen
to you it's got pretty eyes and what if
he doesn't now shoot him that's not
entirely legal
Reacher does have a bit of a Michael
Myers quality about him sure just gonna
walk everywhere can't stop him reach our
dies tonight
jump onto the hood of her car
see Michael Myers
I don't need you screwing up my
investigation this is not your
investigation second babysitting some
giant vagrance hardly my dream this time
and I could be out there looking for who
killed your brother sexual chemistry
I figure it plans to go to Hubble's
house and dig your thumb into his eye
until he tells you I confessed to a
murder he didn't commit something like
that yeah well I'm gonna be there to
make sure that doesn't happen now I can
either follow you the whole way or you
can save the shoe leather and get in the
damn car
time in prison change you Richard
yeah those those 10 minutes in prison
boy for the record I'm not a vagrant I'm
a hobo
details are important in the case Paul
won't be back till late but at least now
I get a chance to thank you Mr Reacher
is that who I think it is is that
Christian
what am I wrong from Smallville yeah
Lana do you know where Paul is
no not specifically she aged terribly
I can't believe they let her on screen
a joke for new viewers
not that sexist well that's what we're
here to find out why my dead brother had
your live husband's number on him
say hi to officer Conklin and Mr Reacher
hello
this is Lucy and tally Tally's growing
like a weed she's the one with the
glasses Lucy's growing wheat we gotta
take her down may I use your restroom
yeah of course through the kitchen down
my own little left Jack [__]
laughs
can't reach for the toilet paper
this is why you can't let hobos into
your house
it's gonna be living in the walls next
ah one she said tally is the one in the
glasses
glasses is the main difference between
the girls everything else was a matter
of degree one wears them one doesn't
okay
right before I was attacked in prison a
guy pointed at me and said him I'd take
in a guy's glasses wow because he wasn't
a nice man
their instructions were clearly to find
the new boys and take out the one in
glasses
hubbles have been smashed he was a
Target not me right oh it's an agrimony
birth they're growing tall grass all
around here we call them hitchhikers
because they stick on you and they go
for a ride sounds like a foxtail
should have came through here
two days ago Moon would have been about
26 degrees further west
check that with James Cameron this is
where he hit
get into the eyes the mind of a killer
you enjoyed it
shooter wanted to be close
it was personal oh someone takes your
life it's always personal
very true
tell me about Joe are you guys tight
now it's not the time for character
development
oh yes
get into a pointless fight with these
people why don't you come here we want
to talk to you no you don't
no you don't what kind of [__] you
bring into our town
oh boy
murder all four of you there's two
Sixers with the empties around your car
you've been waiting a while and I gotta
assume you've been waiting for me rich
guy in a fancy pickup but a 50 in each
of your pockets to take care of me
you man
you're gonna do look at this guy
oh Graham you idiot you're about to get
your ass kicked
gonna break the hands of three drunk
kids
there's four of us here one of you's got
to drive to the hospital nice
I know where the hospital is yes you do
spell just rolled into Market
you've known since last
but she hasn't seen him like mess anyone
up yeah
whoa
we under the car
there's four of them
he's got 100 in their pockets and one of
them knows the weight of the hospital
r1s symbolism
I don't have a clock in there I could
tell at 6am by the Sun
[Laughter]
the shade of the street
it's 604.
okay
well water the dog moment just giving
your dog some water I must have knocked
the bowl over because I gave him water
this morning no you didn't
always blown dry
you calling me a liar oh man he's
cleaning up this town one neighborhood
is done I can't talk right now there's
been another murder police chief
Morrison
wowie what not Findlay it's not Finley
but Morrison's right there John
there's two of them
this Show's so fun yeah
crime scene is worse than anything I
ever saw in Boston and I saw things in
Boston
was he nailed to a wall oh did you know
that just a hunch wait how did he know
that that's what Hubble said that they
would do to him ah
ah yeah good detective skills there John
yeah I pieced that together all by
myself
they were intended to inflict pain
rather than cause death preliminary
examination of police chief Edward
Morrison oh God Cedric has been nailed
to the wall country wow that is graphic
holy crap oh my
[Laughter]
just this one episode We're Not Gonna
blur it
drink it in people
at least four to do that to a guy
Morrison size holy [__]
in his stomach he'll find him during the
autopsy
it's like the Hannibal show the people
Hubble Workforce said they nail him to a
wall and cut his balls off if he cause
problems you said Hubble didn't tell you
anything in jail I lied
so you're saying that Morrison was
working with the same Killers Hubble was
mixed up with
that or we just saw a big fat
coincidence nail to the wall
need to body shame the guy Baker wasn't
concerned because he knew he didn't do
it which means he knows who did why does
a black cop from Boston with a 20-year
pension come work in a Southern
Backwater town in the middle of nowhere
that is a good question mayor Thiel
didn't promote Finley he just appointed
himself acting Chief they skipped you to
get to teal so I guess that means he's
dirty and you're okay and nothing means
more to me than your vote of confidence
[Laughter]
I'm going to call my buddy at the FBI
Teal's first order was no staties no
feds he wants us Captain house we let
him think they've got it under control
for now there's no we here dude keep
saying that but you rely so much on him
came down South for peace and quiet now
I've caught four bodies five
Hubble probably they do this to a cop
one not a banker yep
nah he's fine this is like a procedural
Network show but with streaming quality
yeah absolutely yeah
he had to speak to some people about
sorting out this Bank Madness and when I
woke I realized he'd never come home all
right just a minute
I don't know what to do with them but
they need some kind of protection
I need your car
can't walk this one we will find the
person a person's responsible for these
crimes oh this guy reads crooked
but what the hell do you know about law
enforcement we need a surreal police
chief and a real Chief detective too
he's talking about you oh
boy oh what about that animal you rested
out of the diner I think she's talking
about it
please calm down sit down
sit down oh it's this guy never mind
yeah yeah he always plays good guys when
I mooncline or Industries to this town
five years ago Mark grave was run down
Main Street boarded up right you ever
remember
we suffered through that I will provide
whatever funds to find whomever is
responsible for these heinous acts
you have my word
it's good speech
these killings are not related over the
course of his career Morrison took
countless criminals out of circulation
and the body is by the highway a police
officer was crucified oh boy you're
gonna be a good Captain I think that
takes priority or did they do things
differently up there in Massachusetts
where all the black people are in Black
accuses
told you he's dirty we're prone to agree
but incompetence can look like
malevolence and it's a whole lot more
common
that's a bar couple's wife and kids they
need protection even if Hubble's already
dead these guys get antsy think Charlie
has even a one percent chance of knowing
anything there's even a one percentage
FBI buddy I wanted to reach out to
earlier
Atlanta field office
called
known them for years gave me the best
advice I forgot
don't take the margrave job
we'd be happy to keep you updated on the
investigation just leave your contact
information with the Department before
you head out I'm not leaving I figured
I'd stick around a while margrave's such
a nice town
[Laughter]
FBI Janae Picard is on his way
is taking you into protective custody
Ricardo keep you safe that's what your
husband would have wanted
oh why do you say like that dude have
some awareness reach her your husband's
gone missing so they most likely killed
him too
it'll be time to grieve later you have
to think about your kids to the point
somebody said
[Music]
it's just like Reacher's old bike
oh no
oh kiddo you boys looking for a dance
partner
let's find out
oh no
Billy's dad's back
there's a rage underneath those eyes
hey hey easy
on Picard well that's a relief
wow you're a racist Reacher
Jack racist I told you I need my own gun
they just grab real good
it's like in an instant I'm gonna take a
few personal days watch the family
myself do not let this bite me in the
ass we are talking about my career here
we won't let you get burned better not
no I got bad feeling about that
I told him not to take this job
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm gonna go see that guard Spivey at
warbert whoever paid him to set up
Hubble to be killed is he's running this
thing he won't tell you anything
depends on how I ask
please
I'm desperate I don't know anybody in
this town
detective Finley margrave PD calling on
account of Jack Reacher says he got
tuned up pretty good while under your
roof and now he's suing is there
somewhere we can meet up
get our story straight before lawyers
start sniffing around
I do not want to learn if this actor is
American or not yet wait till the end of
the season yeah I can I can see him
being an Aussie yeah you know I know a
mad detective Finley you sure as hell
don't sound like a black man from Boston
on phone
figured you would set me up so I thought
I'd return the favor
with a fight scene
Boogie
fool Reacher wanted to get caught this
is all part of the plan
let's go
do you know how much he's going to
deduce while riding around in that trunk
no
it's too small
it'll be uncomfortable
well a smart move would be to shoot me
right here but you haven't done that yet
or maybe you have orders to take me to
your boss so we can find out how much I
know
it's for the verification
it means that when I make my move you're
going to hesitate
and you guys know what Cato said about
hesitation right he who hesitates
and wow
wow nice are you done
nicely done man
five seven let me back up the blue cat
food pursuit of one suspect second and
large damn it
it didn't go as planned
I just say the least maybe next time
don't post something like this by
yourself it's not my fault Spivey didn't
buy it I shoved a pole as far up my ass
as I could I still couldn't sound like
you
I want Goons probably military or
ex-military South American spoke Spanish
had Glock 17s and the technique one guy
used to head but me was from a martial
art called ricey hardly anyone uses
except branches of South American
Special Forces
God damn wow turns out Joe was working
for the secret services division of
Homeland doing what your brother could
have been involved in almost anything it
seems maybe Joe was an investigator like
you
good logic
I'm getting a beer absolutely not you
saw those people at town oh they were
ready to grab torches and come after you
like Frankenstein Frankenstein was the
doctor thank you they went after
Frankenstein's monster yes
horror purist Jack Reacher now you can
go to Your Motel right now and sleep in
a comfortable bed or I can arrest you
for vacancy and you can sleep in my old
in town it's not vagrant he's a hobo
mm-hmm
good timing never heard the word vagrant
you so much I know
there's a Roadhouse
Roadhouse nobody knows you there cold
beer Hot music
you gotta behave oh do you want her to
behave huh
oh my God
Sonic is somewhere here requesting chili
dogs
I'm gonna dust up the whole bar
it's not a Twist Off
show off
everything is a Twist off when you Jack
Reacher
that means no
Romance
means we gotta dance when I ask people
to dance it usually precedes a lot of
punching
[Music]
Finley would have loved it here yeah man
he should get out more
oh my God he's gonna go to kiss her but
accidentally headbutt her look you were
a full concussion
[Laughter]
Jack tender no guys it's too soon you
got a case of self it's only episode two
hold it together you've got a case to
solve
oh
oh my God perfect it always rains so
hard in movies and shows I know well
look at this
hell yeah hey take a beat champ we're
far from margrave not far enough
I say go you duck
what's going on Roll these to the
highways flooded no one's getting
through tonight
you're here
time
you always eat this well I was hungry
going straight for the Clark Bar
s are the best like they let you eat
this when you're ready to become Jack
Reacher someone's waiting with a bucket
you want half no
prefer zagner no one prefers
zagged I just my one of my favorite
candies you still have Family Market
the parents died when I was a kid but I
had gray kind of like a second dad he
was the most
studious person I had ever met
fastidious dad I mean the man only had a
horseshoe of hair and he still had
mostly trim it formats a week he
I was depressed a lot
they were married no kids drank wrote a
lot of poetry
hung himself from the rafters in his
garage about a year ago always give me a
tastes on my birthday what about you
cool name hard to kill and very pretty I
hadn't walked in that bar a few days ago
I heard that blind Blake song probably
would have been years before I found out
he was dead in spite of the
circumstances the blue light yeah it's
been nice getting to know you nice
getting to know you too
hmm
it's a very amusing frame he looks so
small you know before we get into it I
could use a real breakfast should I had
the Clark Bar
oh yeah
yeah it's a good thing they weren't
there
pure shoes breaking and entering
came in they tracked through the flower
bed
rubber over shoes
you're gonna kill me
could have been here for me my car was
parked up front is it gonna be here for
me
shh
looks like they plan on coming back
I'm really gonna need a gun
wow
[Music]
so cool Jack
we'll get a cooler is that cooler
yeah
all righty
well well well
I like it more than the movie
yeah I even liked the movie but you know
I like the movie too I didn't I've only
seen it the one time I thought it was
just okay
it was fine it was it was one of the
best guy Courtney performances that's
what stands to reason not this was like
this was this is really this is really
engaging it's really fun uh
admittedly like I I mean I've seen all
kinds of gory Stuff Plus John and I have
uh but I was a little surprised by I
didn't realize this show would go with
that Gore what the curse of fiction I
was like wow that was that was uh
surprisingly uh it's it's like depending
on the show you were watching you
wouldn't be surprised but I was just
surprised it existed in this show yeah
to save that to this episode because
yeah I thought the I thought like yeah
you've had something like gory violence
in here and there but nothing that was
like did that impact
um nothing that's like sick and twist
like yeah it is like a horror movie Kill
yeah uh I I loved I loved that it's here
um because this [__] this show does have
this Vibe currently of
something that feels akin to to a good
Network TV show but it's crossed with
like a good cable show blend at the same
time I could see how it's like really
accessible for everyone because it's got
that like
a Snappy Rhythm about it yeah and and
that fun investigative side but you know
getting to unpack it I'm surprised by
how slow they're doing the Joe building
backstory with them as kids is you get
like like 10 seconds like 10 seconds at
a time it's not a lot and they're just
such isolated incidences of
kids picked on me I'm gonna I'm gonna
fight that they're picking on I'm gonna
fight yeah here's how I learned to Santa
myself here's how I learned to stand up
for other people what'll next episode
show us and I guess it's through the
experiences with Joe that helped shape
Jack Reacher to becoming Jack Reacher uh
and the way they've also developed
Roscoe I really like a lot too because
that's a character that I feel could be
severely underwritten and they do have
like that cliche journey of chemistry
forming uh that is clearly hinting at
sexual romantic entanglement
I would be wondering what season two I'm
already like what was season two because
I could just stay in margrave oh but
yeah I almost have to feel like each
season will be its own crime yeah in a
different part of the country yeah
because it would be interesting to see
how they handle season two already but
uh like you know would you get rid of
these other supporting players because
they're so good you know I like how
they're leading him with Finley actually
did you just cast a black guy like
they're actually using the fact that
he's black as there's some type of like
Richard keeps pointing that out like
you're a black guy from Boston who moved
to this part of the world yeah why why
why you know yeah why would you invite
that on yourself he was probing that to
him so I like that they lean into that
with them and yeah it's just a good
overall
um
like the Mysteries the mystery is fun
right now it's not I'm not like who is
it you know I'm not like quite there yet
trying to outsmart the show figuring out
who it is yeah no no I'm not I'm not
there yet but whatever they're talking
about it and breaking it down uh you you
see just the genius level of intellect
at this buff uh monster is he's
Frankenstein's monster and they but
everyone does have good chemistry and
he's a really good actor I I I I imagine
if it has to be like the hiring in
Reverse I'm just avoiding learning it
yet yeah but it has to be the higher
reverse the higher the actor first and
then buffed him up right I can't be that
way around no buff these guys that
talented
they get paid to become that puff but
they don't just become that buff I
suppose so it would be an undertaking to
get that buff just on the off chance
that you get cast in a role that
requires you to be that buff because
yeah like being that buff is like a
specialty in and of itself the can
pigeonhole you I feel like and just
different kinds of roles
uh but yeah I would I I yeah once we get
to the end of this journey I would be
fascinated to know because he does just
seem so perfectly matched to both the
acting and the physicality of this guy
it's like a real lucky especially after
coming from Tom Cruise it doesn't match
either of those things true to the book
uh you know that doesn't even matter to
us no absolutely another of us has read
the book sentence from any of the books
yeah but even just hearing it and I and
seeing the response to the show clearly
this was a lucky find or or you know a
fortuitous oh he's better
yeah I think I think he's he's more
interesting yeah like before once that's
like I love Tom Cruise I love Tom Cruise
like I go to bat for Tom Cruise you know
and everyone hated Tom Cruise I was
still like I still love him man I'm here
watching Mission Impossible three while
everyone's docking on the gas I remember
that was the time period you made me a
fan I love Tom Cruise made me a Tom
Cruise
um but he's he's just a much more
compelling character here yeah you know
he's so much more compelling I think I
think Tom Cruise was entertaining but
he's just dark Tom Cruise yeah this is
an action this is a genuinely like
really interesting character like the
the way they develop him is fun to to
unpack because
he has
whereas like they really shied away from
the history in the movie they they lean
into it just enough they give you these
tidbits and he feels like a it doesn't
it's not just making mysterious
he's you're you're uncovering who he is
throughout the show yeah
um and it's not just keep it mysterious
you know what I mean like keep him at a
distance they let you in on how he
really feels and how he uh what what
does prove him what does what does
provoke him and what can get emotional
because he does have that like he has to
do a lot of looks with his with his eyes
where you can see where there's a lot of
pain in this guy's past uh but it's not
it doesn't overshadow anything like it's
that's made him like this this focused
bulldog in a lot of ways I love it oh
yeah just he's got a you really feel the
the weight of like he's probably got all
these things like bouncing around in
there and yammering away and he's just
learned over so much time how to act in
spite of those things and so yeah it is
really gratifying to watch a performance
that is just as you know physical and
fun in that respect as it is rich and
nuanced in terms of just watching this
guy think and watching him process and
it's it's interesting because yeah like
there is a procedural element obviously
it's it's a small town crime mystery and
I think the age of streaming has really
led us to like a Heyday for for
especially this because when it was just
Network for most of these procedurals
you get your formula and you get you
know your your you know David Caruso
cliches whereas here I feel like you get
to have all the fun of that but you get
to have
the actual literary tone and because you
can see this being an NBC show but not
as good yeah 100 yeah yeah yeah and so
yeah it is that like cable quality but
still yeah giving you some sort of
mystery that we can all sit there and
like try to unravel and it's not you
know the same array but yeah I think
this this is a really great version of
what this is because there are so many
shows doing this kind of thing both
American shows and and there's a whole
Cottage Korean well I asked them too
Korean but all the others don't have it
nope not at all only Americans all those
Bavarian crime drones that are getting
huge all those shows in Turkey they're
not doing it nope none of them but yeah
I think this uh this is like even just
the way it's slowly unfolding has been
you know like it doesn't feel like you
know we're only two episodes it doesn't
feel like anything is spinning its
Wheels like and like you said it's not
like I'm sitting here going to solve the
mystery like everything they choose to
focus on feels interesting so I'm always
in the moment whether it is a character
scene that's just intimate whether it is
them's you know sussing out some kind of
detail they go to the town hall meeting
and I thought that was really nicely uh
played in the way that yeah you are
seeing the way people feel and you have
that element of like okay it wasn't as
explicit the first episode but
especially here now like the way certain
people just in the town are referring to
Finley and how they feel about his
presence here yeah you you start to see
you know more of the picture and I think
the casting of a guy like Bruce McGill
to be the the mayor like he always shows
up in in stuff that takes place in
places like this and he plays characters
on both sides of the morality oftentimes
uh so I think he's like a great you know
choice to where he's got the chops but
if you recognize him you can kind of
play off of what you know about him too
so it's like clever casting and the
other guy too who's uh who is the other
sort of main presence in the room who
takes over and kind of gets everybody
back you know the industrial man yeah
yeah him the money man that guy whose
name I don't know but who I've seen a
bunch of times you have probably both
crooked yeah and suddenly In Cahoots
maybe I mean and part of me wonders to
what to go like I could see it being
searched a certain kind of thing where
one of them is very much like in on the
crime and the other one maybe is just an
accessory and I'm wondering like to what
degree is he aware but either way you
have these I think the casting choices
and where they choose to put more
recognizable faces versus less
recognizable faces Kristin cruick is
also was it her do we do we verify it
let's make sure I don't want IMDb to
tell me if she's in multiple episodes
here I'll I'll look it might it might
show up actually since I was on Amazon
it does that thing where when you play
the episode you can see the cast you can
see the cast yeah yeah but uh but yeah I
thought this this just continued on you
know unfolding in a lovely kind of
gradual way and uh
yeah some really harsh like when they do
check back into the crime like they are
really good at creating this paranoia
and and the sense that like nowhere is
safe and I like these different players
they have come in and like you got this
FBI guy to worry about in the family and
then you've got these South American
Hired Hands it is Kristen crew hey
it's good to see her again good for her
killing it
she looks great
yeah she does how old is she I don't
know crh she's 30.
25. oh my God she just turned 18.
do you think uh
my wife would be cool with allowing her
to come into the bedroom with us sure
you know definitely baby
it's Smallville it's Kristin cruick
watch this episode of Jack you'll see
what I mean cannot pass this opportunity
not at all it's a Once in a Lifetime we
all have a hall pass
yeah I've said it for days now
Christopher
that's right for days
yes and now it's 20 46 and we finally
she is now 55 years old and I'm waiting
it's okay that's that's when you all
have the life experience to really make
it a good
Trio
a good menajah Greg
oh this joke is so funny to me it's
gonna happen the way to go it's gonna
happen so many years wait for it okay
yeah man commit to it now Build It Up
over time so that when it happens it's
not a surprise
um it's many years in the making uh yeah
she was kind of cool I guess I think
there's something more suspicious to her
yeah it's that accent
it's one of those shows too where I
where I want to know from anybody who
spent time in the area like how
authentic are the actors that was her
actual speaking voice The Voice you hear
in Smallville is could you make this
more like like uh Ohio All-American yeah
rather than than Southern mccaster to be
a woman in small town that's right man
that's that's her pigeon hole like
Street Fighter the legendary yeah man
small town Chun that's what they call it
yeah man Ace reporter
ah uh no she was good though she was
good everyone's good everyone's good
this is a fun show and the core cast is
great uh and uh too the way they've
orchestrated the whole like reluctantly
working together thing and the tension
of that and the circumstances
surrounding it I think that's been
building nicely too he doesn't have that
gun yet but we'll get there did all I
mean I gotta find this out did all
episodes of Reacher release at once
because Amazon likes to have fun with
that
um
how oh God
you could you could search like reach
her air dates or just look at the IMDb
and it'll it probably will tell in the
in the episodes uh
or not the IMDb the Wikipedia
um it'll probably tell if and where the
episodes would have aired
I just learned the ending
um
All released at once yeah okay yeah
because I was gonna say this feels like
it was designed to be watch that once
but it works episodically like more than
certain shows like I would believe if
you told me this was episodic week to
week
well it's good stuff guys
um what did you all think leave your
thoughts down below
um and keep a lookout for our reaction
episode three let's end this with a pair
Daniel Gallagher I wanna show you Daniel
Gallagher
into town
expertise Daniel Gallagher that is the
show
will be Gallagher and you'll smash some
watermelons just because that's the joke
before gonna go directly towards so we
better just give the people what they
want so keep your language and we'll see
you next time love you Daniel and reach
for the stars
[Music]